she is a muslim feminist and the author
of standing alone an american woman
struggle for the soul of islam astra
nomani
hey how are you
thank you what a great pleasure to meet
you uh
i don't often say this to the guest
right off but you are a hero of mine
you really are the way you stand up for
the things that i've been trying to say
but it's
me it's comes it means so much more
coming from you
because i'm not a muslim and you are so
can this be mutual gratification
yes please do just pour it on because
seriously
you have honestly taken a position of
moral courage
i'm a feminist liberal muslim i know a
lot of contradiction in terms there
head spinning but you have dared to
challenge
liberals to stand by their values and
and i'm winning a lot of them over by
the way
you are i really am it's it's amazing
how they used to boo me and now they
don't
i i posted that i was coming on your
show and got more likes than those cat
videos i want you know what i was
i want to read this i was in ames iowa
i'd go on the road you know doing my
stand-up last weekend somebody handed
this letter to the
stage manager i won't read the guy's
name he might not want it he says dear
bill maher
watching your show i have heard you ask
where are the moderate muslims
i am a former political prisoner from
saudi arabia
the moderate muslims are in jail right
right because
where did extremism get born
it was born in saudi arabia it was born
out of this theology of islam that we
don't want to accept
and today the sad testimony in paris
we don't know completely what has
happened but ak-47s
suicide vests targeted attacks probably
not the amish
right right and so president obama says
that he's going to go after the
terrorists speculate who and he's going
to
go after the terrorist networks but we
don't mention what kind of terrorist
networks
it's crazy yeah that i don't understand
that and i also don't understand
liberals who don't understand this man
who says the moderates are in jail
how could liberals who stood for black
people getting to go to college
in the 60s and then when i was in
college they were protesting apartheid
in south africa
how can they how can they not stand up
against sharia law
which is the law in so many muslim
countries which is a law of oppression
yeah i don't understand it either but
what i have figured out is that they
run scared they're afraid of the name
calling that you're
get targeted with the name calling that
i get targeted with
they don't want to look bad they don't
want to act like they are intolerant of
a minority community
but at the end of the day they are on
the side of
the progressive muslims the people who
believe
in sexism and bigotry they're on the
wrong side it must be even
more uh frustrating for you because
to for someone to shout you down you've
lived this life
you've actually borne the pain i mean
let's get a little into your story you
were born in india
you lived in pakistan you were with a
boyfriend there
yeah you got pregnant out of wedlock
and he left you yeah because why because
they always blame the woman
yeah well the man can go the woman is
left with the evidence
of the crime of having had the sex the
crime yeah i was
uh in pakistan after september 11th to
cover
the war there and i fell in love took
too seriously the make love not war
patch of my youth yeah um
yes and then i learned i was pregnant
and
i learned i was pregnant four weeks
into this other horrible moment that had
happened
when my colleague from the wall street
journal left a home that i had rented in
karachi pakistan
never to return daniel pearl danny pearl
you were the last person to talk to him
man
yeah and danny i waved goodbye to him i
said see you later buddy
and he didn't come back i learned later
that the men who had killed him had done
so in the name of islam
they had beheaded him as you know
they had wiped them the floor
of the blood from his murder and then
laid down their prayer rugs
as if they had divine ordination for
what they had just done
well that's my problem with religion one
of them is that they
they take something horrific and make it
something sacred i am absolutely sure
that isis thinks
everything they do every horrific crime
every atrocity
is is an act of justice and an act for
god right and so
when i was sitting there in karachi and
i learned i was pregnant my boyfriend
bailed on me
and i was criminal according to the laws
of isis the laws of pakistan
pakistan yeah the laws of pakistan and
you know i had this uh
existential moment of the kind that you
talk about all the time
why bother you know where is any good in
all of this
and for me i didn't have the courage to
tell my father of course
he's the patriarch in my family so my
mom took him out to dinner which she's
never done in her life
and they went to the crab shack in
morgantown west virginia
and i got an email and he said allah is
so i know your arabic's not so great but
that means
yes yes that means god is beneficial god
is merciful
and so my parents showed me a grace and
the type of tolerance compassion and
love that they had raised me with in
islam that made me a journalist that
made me a friend of danny
even though he was a jew right this was
the excuse
that the murderers used to kill him
and i don't think any of us who
criticize islam are denying that that
element
is there yeah it's just not right now
ascendant
it doesn't seem to be where the energy
is yeah so when i get accused of
demonizing islam nicholas kristoff who i
consider a friend was on our show we had
a big debate about this last year
i saw him recently said you know bill
maher demonizes
islam because a small percentage of the
faith are extremist
first of all i'm not demonizing i'm
characterizing how did we get to this
place where just describing something is
demonizing
and i'm not so sure it's a very small
percentage maybe a small percentage who
carry out terrorist acts
but it's not a small percentage right
who believe in some of the illiberal
ideas that support terrorists right
because ultimately
i don't even believe that a woman should
get less inheritance than a
brother right but ultimately what has
happened is that
the reporting that i've done is that
there is this entire network
of bloggers activists academics who are
from the largest national muslim
organizations like this council on
american islamic relations the highest
places in the ivory towers of america
like
uh georgetown university and uc berkeley
a favorite of yours i know i was invited
and disinvited just the way you were
invited and disinvited
right and and what has happened is that
i call them the honor brigade and what
they do
is they smear somebody like you somebody
like me
for being witness to truth because
ultimately the truth
frightens the the them the liberals
get on board and unfortunately you've
had the deniers um
and the deflectors on board you've and
then you've had sam harris majid nawaz
ayan hirsi ellie
ishan manji and now the honor brigade
comes after me
because i'm on with you also that's just
crazy i mean i find it a badge of honor
to be disinvited by the way
and that's and
we're and we're at a place in history
where we have to challenge what does it
mean to be honorable
right it is not honorable and what does
it mean to be liberal
yes and and we have to stand up for the
truth liberal values
in your book you have a great thing it's
the islamic
bill of rights for women right you wrote
a bill of rights
and some of the things in it seem like
they to us
shouldn't even need to be written down
right like the right to
say whether you want to have sex or not
it seems like it should be
yeah it's a radical idea radical idea uh
what are some of the other things in the
bill of rights well my first one was the
right of a woman to have an orgasm very
radical idea
i mean in a lot of places the right of a
woman
to have a clitoris because that is
ultimately that's you know that wasn't a
joke
right because ultimately this is very
intentional because
when you have this term of female
genital mutilation you remove the right
woman's right to pleasure
so there's the right of a woman to say
no
because there is this idea that the
angels will curse a woman until morning
if she denies her husband
sex and so these are just basic human
rights
and i ultimately believe that they are
rights that islam does validate
because while the
many of the principles that are being
practiced today
are cons you know unequal
and and sexist the religion came
as a progressive faith in the seventh
century
we just stayed stuck in the seventh
century right so we need to fast forward
to the 21st century
well what happened in paris last night
there last night or tonight yeah will
that change anything do you think
my mother says that it's almost like the
world needs so much blood to be spilled
to wake up
and what i say is just what you're
saying is wake up
you know we have to be honest about the
fact that there is an ideology of islam
that is our war of our generation
and this is an ideology that we have to
address and we have to address it with
moral courage
and you do guarantee tomorrow bigot
islamophobe but thank you for doing what
you do
all right i'll see you again soon